Новини дня «heute» з Барбарою Гальвеґ.
Добрий вечір усім.
Норберт Кеніґ сьогодні розповість
про новини спорту.
Погляньмо на теми сьогоднішнього випуску.
Заходи щодо зниження споживання газу:
міністр економіки Габек планує
збільшити обсяги виробництва
електроенергії на вугільних електростанціях.
Скандал у партії AfD:
після запеклої суперечки
про політику щодо Європи й Росії
з'їзд партії в Різі завершився передчасно.
Евакуація через лісову пожежу:
у Бранденбурзі сотні мешканців
вимушені залишити свої домівки.
Очільник громади оголосив надзвичайний стан.
На тлі сьогоднішньої спеки дивно говорити про
зимові морози.
Але скорочення постачання газу з Росії
заганяє Німеччину на слизьке.
Міністр економіки
називає ситуацію «серйозною»
і пропонує нові заходи
щодо забезпечення газопостачання.
Наразі в Німеччині газосховища
заповнені тільки на 57%.
За прогнозами, 1-го листопада
цей показник становитиме 90%.
Однак цього не вистачить,
щоб пережити зиму.
Олександра Вакано розповість про те,
що може нам допомогти.
Замість газу - більше вугільних електростанцій.
Саме вони тепер знову мають
виробляти більше електроенергії -
на лихо міністрові з партії Зелених.
Однак, як каже Габек, серйозна ситуація
вимагає серйозних кроків.
Відповідний закон
має набути чинності вже в липні.
Фактично це кам'яновугільні електростанції.
Вони дають більше викидів CO2,
ніж газотурбінні електростанції,
тож це важкий крок для мене.
Та він необхідний.
Сховища потрібно наповнювати газом.
Вони можуть вміщувати кількість газу,
яка виробляє
приблизно 256 ТВт·год енергії.
Цього вистачає на два або три зимові місяці.
Загалом щороку країна споживає
така кількість природного газу,
яка виробляє приблизно 1000 ТВт·год енергії.
Тому уряд надає
мережевим операторам 15 млрд євро,
щоб сприяти закупівлі газу
й заповненню сховищ.
Для промислових підприємств
запроваджують модель газового аукціону.
Вона має стимулювати
компанії заощаджувати газ,
щоб потім продати його на ринку.
На думку Габека,
промисловість - це вирішальний фактор.
Наразі німецькі підприємства
намагаються заощаджувати газ,
їх непокоять порожні сховища, адже потім
їхнє виробництво може зупинитися.
Нам буде необхідно заповнити всі сховища
і водночас намагатися
знайти якомога більше інших джерел.
Нам потрібно буде змінити
систему постачання палива,
наприклад, нафти.
Представники партії FDR пропонують
ще одне джерело енергії -
«фрекінг», технологія
видобування природного газу.
Її заборонено використовувати з 2017 року
з екологічних міркувань.
Нам потрібно розглянути можливість
розвитку власного потенціалу
через видобування так званого сланцевого газу
у безпечному середовищі.
Адже насправді зараз ми його імпортуємо,
та не видобуваємо самостійно.
З погляду збереження довкілля
нам було б вигідно видобувати його самостійно.
Міністр економіки Німеччини рішуче відкидає
можливість використання технології фрекінгу.
Наразі навколо газопостачання
тривають палкі дебати,
хоча до зими, здається, ще далеко.
Більше на цю тему - в програмі «berlin direkt»
одразу після нашого випуску.
Скандал в AfD: члени партії передчасно завершили
партійний з'їзд після запеклої суперечки
щодо антиєвропейської резолюції.
Напередодні Тіно Хрупалла та Аліс Вайдель,
яких лише вчора було
обрано очільниками партії,
кілька разів не змогли домогтися свого.
Подробиці розповість Крістіане Гюбшер.
Передчасне завершення, аби не сталося гіршого.
Сьогодні нарешті мало б відбутися
предметне обговорення,
та вже вранці на з'їзді партії панує незгода.
У центрі дискусії -
пропозиція приймати до AfD
організації, які пов'язані
з правими екстремістами.
Противники ідеї шоковані.
Ми серйозно плануємо мати справи
з людьми, які виходять на вулиці
разом з NPD й іншими екстремістами.
Не робімо таких дурниць!
Бйорн Геке підтримує пропозицію й скидає маску,
демонструючи своє справжнє обличчя
очільникам партії, яким він вчора
допоміг обійняти посаду.
Тому завдяки нашій силі,
нашій самоповазі, нашій волі
ми визначаємо, хто є екстремістом
і від кого ми відмежовуємося.
Ситуація загострилася, коли почалося обговорення
антиєвропейської резолюції.
Упродовж більш як двох годин
нові очільники партії, Хрупалла й Вайдель,
намагаються перенести голосування,
проте щоразу даремно.
Це спроба завадити голосуванню.
Цей документ необхідно негайно
винести на голосування.
Будь ласка, не кричімо одне на одного.
Я вимагаю завершити
цей з'їзд партії, це негідно.
Ще трохи - і ми тут саморозпустимося.
Я не хочу, щоб ухвалювали резолюцію,
яка набирає 55% голосів.
Зрештою, Хрупаллі необхідна підтримка
кількох очільників федеральних земель,
щоб таки домогтися свого.
Перший день новообраного
партійного керівництва -
і його вже дискредитують.
З нами на зв'язку Ніколь Дікман
з міста Різа в Саксонії.
Це був поганий початок
для нового керівництва AfD, чи не так?
Так, можна досить впевнено це стверджувати.
Новий дует очільників партії,
які на посаді лише 24 години,
вже зараз змушені
зазнавати важких поразок.
Тут, у Різі, авторитетові
Аліс Вайдель і Тіно Хрупалли
завдав удару правий екстреміст Геке.
Упродовж перших двох днів з'їзду він
приховував свою силу, а тепер показав її.
Він хотів і проголосив новий старт для нарешті
об'єднаної AfD, яка зазнала нищівної поразки.
Результат цього триденного з'їзду в Різі
радше виглядає як хаос,
а традиційно конфліктна партія має
нове, але вже дискредитоване керівництво,
яке зазнало поразки в боротьбі за владу
проти Геке та його прибічників.
Ніколь Дікман прояснила нам ситуацію,
щиро дякую.
У Франції до 20:00 триватиме
другий тур парламентських виборів.
Йдеться про обрання
572 депутатів Національних зборів,
яких ще не обрали на першому турі.
За результатами останніх опитувань,
партійний союз прибічників президента Макрона
може втратити абсолютну більшість.
Тиждень тому «ліво-зелений» союз
під керівництвом конкурента Макрона
Меланшона отримав майже
стільки ж голосів, скільки й «макроністи».
Генеральний секретар НАТО
Столтенберг припускає, що війна в Україні
може тривати роками.
Тому він закликає не зупинятися у підтримці країни
в інтерв'ю для видання «Bild am Sonntag».
Росіяни знову атакували Дніпропетровщину.
За повідомленнями місцевої влади,
вибухнув резервуар з пальним.
Тривають запеклі бої на Луганщині.
Українська сторона повідомляє
про чергові інтенсивні обстріли.
І знову до новин Німеччини.
Смертельне поєднання
спеки, вітру та посухи -
з п’ятниці лісова пожежа в Бранденбурзі
неконтрольовано поширюється,
і сьогодні мешканці кількох районів
мусили евакуюватися.
Лісова ділянка розташована
приблизно за 40 км від Потсдама,
ліс палає поблизу містечка Троєнбрітцен,
а також біля Беліца.
Сюжет Кетрін Лінднер з Троєнбрітцена.
Уже третій день ситуація без змін:
полум'я продовжує поширюватися.
Наразі на місці працюють понад
650 працівників служб екстреної допомоги.
Пожежу важко загасити,
адже на території залишилися
нездетоновані боєприпаси.
Однак з минулого вечора Бундесвер
почав надавати підтримку з повітря.
Я стою на межі зони пожежі.
Ви можете побачити, як сильно дме вітер.
Однак зараз саме вітру тут і бояться,
його сили й напрямку.
З міркувань безпеки мешканців
кількох районів було евакуйовано.
Понад 600 осіб змушені були
покинути свої домівки.
Водночас Саксонія-Ангальт і Берлін
пообіцяли свою підтримку.
Найбільша небезпека полягає в тому,
що ми перебуваємо на лісистих пагорбах,
і вітер не вщухає.
Ми дуже сподіваємося,
що вночі почне дощити.
Це б нам допомогло.
Проте ця лісова пожежа вже давно
не єдина в цьому регіоні,
всього за кілька кілометрів звідси
неконтрольовано палає
територія поблизу міста Беліц.
А зараз - новини від Норберта.
Позавчорашня поразка команди «Альба Берлін»
не стала для неї вироком.
Третя перемога в четвертій грі проти Баварії
з рахунком 96:81 принесла берлінцям
у столиці Баварії
черговий національний титул.
Водночас команда вже вшосте перемагає
в національному чемпіонаті та кубку.
Останні два роки берлінці перемагають
на чемпіонаті в Мюнхені.
Через два дні після прикрої
локальної поразки в третій грі фінальної серії
«жовті» домінують цього разу з самого початку гри.
Джейлен Сміт набрав 23 очки -
найрезультативніший гравець матчу.
Баскетболістам Баварії доводиться
знову визнати свою поразку.
Для «Альби» це 11-й чемпіонський титул.
Сінья Тільман і Свенья Мюллер здобули «бронзу»
на чемпіонаті світу з пляжного волейболу в Римі.
Команді-суперниці зі Швейцарії
довелося вибути в другому сеті,
тому що Йоана Гайдріх вивихнула плече
під час подачі.
Дві бронзові медалі з художньої гімнастики,
а отже перші за останні 42 роки
медалі чемпіонату Європи для Німеччини
принесла 15-річна Дар'я Варфоломеєв з Тель-Авіва.
Вона посіла третє місце на фінальних вправах
з м’ячем і з булавами.
Тенісний турнір на траві в місті Галле у Вестфалії
виграє, на диво, поляк
Губерт Гуркач у двох сетах
проти Данила Медведєва з Росії.
Данило Медведєв уявляв цю гру геть інакше.
Гра проти поляка Губерта Гуркача тривала 62 хв
без шансів для російської першої ракетки світу.
Без жодної перерви він
зазнав поразки проти 12-ї ракетки світу
у двох сетах.
Навряд чи Гуркач міг отримати
кращу рекомендацію
перед розпалом сезону «Вімблдону» за тиждень.
Завтра нас чекає менша спека, але більше гроз.
На Північному сході
та в центральних регіонах - зливи й грози,
на решті територій - хмарно або сонячно,
на Півдні вдень пройдуть сильні грози.
Максимальна температура - 17-24°C,
на Півдні - до 33°C.
О 21:45 вас вітатиме Крістіан Зіверс
із випуском «heute journal».
А завтра у студії «heute»
на вас чекатиме Мітрі Зірін.
А ми прощаємося й дякуємо за перегляд.
Ефір продовжить Тео Коль
із випуском «berlin direkt».